[Music]
pre-college program is really to give
you an understanding of what college
might be like the college itself has so
many interesting courses there's so many
different programs for mean there's
engineering there's mathematics there's
English there's Art and Design
I have students on my floor that like
when one's in a ballet class ones in a
computer science class and I just love
the diversity of it the faculty here is
incredible they're all here because they
invest in their students they're all
here because they want to improve their
students they want to give a summer of
learning as well as fun the faculty is
just been amazing and the TAS especially
they go here they're current students
and they just seem so happy with it
we're all extremely dedicated to this
and we really want them to have the best
experience that they've had ever by
hosting programs and like bringing them
together like we like help them form a
community we help the kids become more
comfortable in their environment it's
really interesting I mean since we're
all coming from completely different
places from as closest right here in
Pittsburgh - as far as Guam you can see
all of these different types and like
meet people that are just like you and
then people that are interested in
different things but you form such
strong relationships with those people
and it's absolutely amazing the campus
is absolutely beautiful
and it's it feels it's like a place you
can live that's a place that you could
like to stay here and be comfortable
with I love Pittsburgh I don't even know
what else to say like I just I love the
city there are all these amazing places
everywhere within like the finest of bus
or even by walking downtown is like a
ten minute bus ride that's free
Pittsburgh I think is one of the coolest
cities ever because it has so many like
sections like your shady side of
Squirrel Hill you know south side you
have downtown you have the waterfront we
went to Kenny one Cedar Point and I feel
like our program does a really good job
of providing excellent like fun
experiences for each type of person this
program has absolutely everything you
could ever want you get an excellent
education like a very good idea of what
your classes are gonna be like in
college you get to make friendships that
are going to last you farther than the
summer all of this happens it
institutions that they get to learn from
the best professor is wonderful if
anyone was looking for a great college
experience maybe some extra credit or
just trying to learn something new for
their summer trying to make the most of
their summer meeting new people
exploring a whole new place they should
definitely come to pre-college at CMU
best place ever
[Music]